a little happy day outliers in
woodworkers mana here with heartwood art
do you have a messy garage or shed full
of garden tools that you could never
find well that's easy and cheap DIY
palette project it's gonna solve that
problem for you now I'm gonna take you
on a short video tour of how I built
this but for all the details come on
over to heartwood art comm and see each
step in the process plus how to fully
customize it okay let's dive in and
since this palette will be freestanding
meaning that it won't be attached to the
wall will be adding feet to it to ensure
that it can't tip forward so the first
thing we'll want to do is stand the
palette up to find the most level in
that will make less work for you to
level it to add the feet later
now while the palette is stood up insert
your long handle tools to get an idea of
best placement for them and determine
how many cross rails you'll need to cut
so that you can easily lift them out
I had an industrial pallet that was 45
by 45 inches and I had to remove the top
three cross rails so lay your pallet on
the floor and cut those cross rails I
use my circular saw guide to make a
straight cut and to support the saw as
the rails fell out and you can see how
to make a guide like this yourself over
at hurt wood art okay now let's add the
feet I used two of those rails that we
cut out and I'm mounting them flush to
the back but you can have them stick out
in the back a little bit if you want to
mine stuck out the front by 11 inches
and that was enough to make the pallet
tip roof I used number 8 by 1 and 3/4
construction screws and drill pilot
holes with a countersink to get the
screw head flush or below the plane of
the wood ok let's move on to mounting
the tools I have several axes and wanted
to mount them on the bottom front shelf
now because they're so heavy
I thought supports running through the
pallet would be a good idea I use more
of those rail cut-offs for this and
because I had a back and front rail
parallel that's how I decided to mount
them
just now that the support rails could
interfere with your long handle tool
placement so be sure to check that tool
placement again before you mount the
supports and I attach them with screws
into the back rail and then next I built
that act shelf I just happened to have
torn down another pallet that was the
same size and I had a scrap piece that
was exactly the right width and length
so that's what I used i clamped that
piece to the lip of my bench then I
glued and clamped a scrap 1x2 for the
lip edge and tacked it in with my nail
gun using 1 and 1/4 inch brad dales okay
this was a little bit tricky I stood the
pallet on its side so I could screw the
Shelf to the supports from underneath
there was nowhere to clamp so I used the
pickaxe
as a spacer okay now it's time to mark
our tools for Dow placement I used these
pre-cut groove Dells because they're the
same size of the corresponding drill bit
and they expand a little when wet with
glue down rods tend to be a little
smaller than the corresponding drill bit
and they're not the easiest thing to cut
squarely either so drill your holes and
try not to go all the way through then
glue your dowels in fit snug using a
rubber mallet
I like that bottom act shell so much
that I decided to build a few more
shelves on the front of the right side I
made them the same way as the act shelf
but since they wouldn't be holding much
weight I simply glued clamped and tacked
nailed them into the Crossrail from the
back now a few of my tools were perfect
for hanging so it decided to add angled
dowels to the front of the cross rails
on the left side you really don't have
to angle the drill very much to get this
effect and I did drill all the way
through so it can insert a little more
of the dowel as these would be holding a
bit of weight and I also had a few
screwin type J hooks and I mounted them
on the side to hold these dirt breaker
things for lack of knowing what else to
call them
all it took was drilling a pilot hole
first and they screwed right in now on
the other side I wanted to hang my ice
scraper my two and 1/2 inch construction
screws had enough of a smooth shoulder
that one of them were perfectly for
hanging the handle without marring the
surface of it and last I wanted a place
to put my kneepads I used another piece
of the Crossrail boards I cut out and
mounted it to one of the inner structure
blocks it was the perfect width to mount
inside there and to hold my kneepads now
my garden tools get pretty dirty so I
decided not to paint my pallet but you
certainly could if you want an even more
rustic look by giving it a whitewash or
using milk paint or such I hope you've
enjoyed this quick tour of how to build
this garden tool storage pallet project
come on over to Marlin art.com
and see all the details on it and get
more easy bills like this too and I'll
see you in the shop